let's begin today with a trip down
memory lane i want to take you back to
ancient history to a time that our
forefathers told us about all the way
back to june 24th 2021. in those days of
yore something happened which the media
certainly hopes to leave buried under
the sand out of sight and out of mind
and out of memory it was the incident at
the wii spa in los angeles as you may
still recall if you're as old as me and
you can think back to all the way back
to three months ago the wii spa was the
site of controversy when a woman who
goes by cubana angel on instagram
uploaded a video of herself confronting
the spa staff over a naked man who
exposed himself inside the women's
locker room
she said that she was in the locker room
along with a bunch of other women and
young girls when the man entered and
revealed himself in all of his maleness
to the females in the room
to refresh our memories let's watch a
little bit of the conversation between
cubana angel and the staff towards the
end of this clip you also you'll also
get to see the mustachioed white knight
gallop into the scene to stick up for
the naked exhibitionist man in the
locker room and condemn the woman for
her big her her bigotry and her
transphobia let's watch that again
so you don't so it's okay i just want to
be clear with you it's okay
it's okay for a man to go into the
women's section
show his penis
around the other women young little
girls under age your spa we spa condone
that is that what you're saying
like i asked
it's so he he can stay there
he could stay there
what sexual orientation i see
it lets me know he's a man
he he's a man
he is a man he is not no female
he is not a female
he is not a female
give her her money back are you talking
about the transgender there's no such
thing as transgender he has a
okay
he has a penis he has penises hanging
out
okay no i'm not one actually i'm a woman
who knows how to stand up and speak up
for my right as a woman i have a right
to feel comfortable without a man
exposing himself okay no you go
somewhere else
okay so that's right
no he's not a transgender he has a penis
just like you do
are you are you are you are you i
understand no yeah
okay it's not okay it's not okay okay
that's traumatizing to see that i'm a
woman
i think this is a place right here i'm
told only for women so how dare you sit
up here and tell me i don't have a right
as a woman
i'm telling you he has a penis
a full and testicle okay
and my favorite thing about that video
has always been
when you hear the white knight in the
background and you don't see him yet and
he says are you talking about the
transgender person
and uh and then the camera pans over and
before you see him you have an image in
your head of what this guy is going to
look like and he looks exactly like him
it's like a premonition you know exactly
what he's gonna look like and he looks
like that and uh and then you got the
smarmy look on his face the entire time
while this woman is trying to explain
basic biology no no he has a penis and
testicles that's a that's a man that's a
man
and the white knight's standing there
like oh okay all right this
condescending look as if
as if he's the one talking to a crazy
person when it's the other way around so
the staff was against her the white
knight was against her a man had
stripped off his clothes in front of her
without her consent and most of the
people in the building were taking the
man's side
and this pattern would hold true on a
larger scale the left-wing social media
mob the entire mainstream media along
with the antifa terrorists who showed up
at the wii spa in the following days to
assault and intimidate the small group
of protesters who came to support kibana
angel and the other female victims in
the case all of these groups condemned
the women
as bigots and transphobes
even as hoaxers and scam artists here's
a quick sample of some of the headlines
related to this incident from slate
violence over an alleged transphobic
hoax shows the danger of underestimating
anti-trans hate the independent lgbtq
advocates suggest alleged trans exposure
incident
at the la spa was faked
pink news says bigot screaming at spa
staff for not being transphobic sparks
furious protests
the guardian a nightmare scenario how an
anti-trans instagram post led to
violence in the streets
in the new republic how tucker carlson
and a story about a possibly fictional
trans person fueled two weeks of violent
right-wing protests
there was an article in the advocate
titled was trans nudity incident at los
angeles spa staged
and this
article actually suggests
that the whole thing may have been a
right-wing false flag operation
this was published on july 9th the piece
reads a trans activist and journalist
writing under the pseudonym robert
lansing says the whole thing may have
been an elaborate hoax
quote a source of the spot told the
blade there's no record of of any of its
usual transgender clients on its
appointments guest list on the day in
question lansing wrote in an article
published on wednesday
treatment at the spa is by appointment
only and most of its transgender clients
are well known to the staff
also anonymous sources with the los
angeles police department told lansing
there's no corroborating evidence that a
trans person was at we spa that day no
obviously trans person can be seen in
the video and no other clients have
offered evidence either
a woman falsely accused of being the
trans woman who so offended cuban angel
has been harassed and received death
threats it also remains a possibility
that there was a person unknown to the
wii spa staff who pretended to be
transgender to create an inciting
incident lansing continued in 2015
anti-transgender activists in washington
state deliberately encouraged men to
enter women's women's facilities
one cisgender man entered a swimming
pool changing area wearing only board
shorts while claiming that he had a
right to be there
he was removed from the premises without
charges being filed
ah yes so it didn't happen
but if it did happen it was a right-wing
conspiracy
that's what they decided to go with
they also claimed that there's no
evidence that this trans person
exists
even though multiple women can be heard
in the video reporting that they just
saw the guy's penis in the women's
locker room five seconds earlier
apparently multiple women testifying to
their experiences does not count as
evidence
that's no evidence
at least it doesn't count as evidence
when the person being accused is trans
if the person accused was a straight
white conservative male
a quote unquote cisgender male as they
say
all it would take is one woman
testifying to something that allegedly
occurred at any point within the last
half century and that would qualify not
just as evidence but as indisputable
proof
that's the way these things work as we
have seen
now the headlines just cited are some of
the more egregious examples but every
headline about this case in the
left-wing press
was along these lines
they all agreed that the women who
complained about the transgender person
were hateful transphobes that the whole
thing was probably some sort of hoax
that was the media spin until the last
few weeks
when they suddenly stopped talking about
the story altogether
and if you're wondering why they all
felt so eerily silent
why the left stopped condemning the
horrific transphobia of cubana angel and
her conspirators
it's because the full truth has come out
and the truth is
well the truth is exactly what you
should expect
the quote-unquote trans woman who
entered the locker room that day
is a sex offender with a long history of
allegations and convictions his name is
darren mirager he's 52 years old he's
now wanted by police on six felony
charges of indecent exposure after five
females at the wii spa that day five of
them including one minor reported to
police
that he exposed his erect penis to them
in the locker room
he now has two warrants for his arrest
stemming from this incident and has not
turned himself into into the police
the new york post has more information
about this sex predator who every
left-wing media outlet in the country
defended
it says quote
sources tell the post that mirager
had been banned by we spa back in 2019
due to customer complaints of an
erection in the women's section
but mirager wasn't recognized by the
front desk in june because they were
wearing a mask
we spa did not respond for comment
mirager says he was interviewed by the
post and he says i don't remember being
banned adding that there was one
complaint but maintains it was meritless
and based on transphobia mirager who
stands six foot two and weighs around
200 pounds says the women are mistaking
a large appendage for an erection merger
says i don't have a small penis but you
can't say that's an erection what if you
use the men's room and someone said they
don't like the size or shape of your
penis that's what they're doing
but this isn't roger's first incident of
indecent exposure mirager was convicted
in 2003 for looking through the window
of an elderly woman's home in california
while masturbating
um he says quote i may have been
somewhere i didn't belong but i wasn't
doing it for sexual gratification and i
wasn't showing myself off mirage or
contest
roger says it was a mistake to plead
guilty when asked if he if he was there
and masturbated on the property and
roger said i don't remember that night
so i can't comment it was a long time
ago
oh yes he doesn't remember doesn't
remember if he masturbated in front of
an elderly woman's window or not
well maybe i did maybe i can't remember
so long ago
now it may sound difficult to believe
that a person wouldn't remember whether
or not they did that
but considering how often this guy
allegedly exposes himself to women
there may be some truth to it he's just
having trouble keeping it all straight
more from the post it says mirager has
also been implicated in sex crime
investigations that did not result in
charges in june 2018 while on parole for
a burglary conviction mirager was
identified as a suspect in an alleged
indecent exposure incident at a gasoline
station
according to police report three
customers reported to the cashier that a
person with no underwear wearing a
see-through fishnet style outfit was
exposing themselves at a pump
then on december 26 2018
police responded to the palm springs
swim center after the coaches of a high
school girls water polo team called
police according to the incident report
one of the coaches said he aggressively
confronted mirager after the schoolgirls
alerted him
that mirager had exposed his penis in
the women's changing room
um and by the way as i was reading that
from the new york post and i kept using
uh his and him
but the new york post was using there
because you know
it's important when we're talking about
a
sex offender who is exposing himself to
young girls it's important to respect
his pronouns still
so to review
a 52 year old male sex predator with a
long history of harassing women
including the elderly and children
entered a female locker room
exposed his erect penis to a group of
women and a child
the victims then complained to the staff
who all took the sex offender's side
and the media took the sex offender's
side
the left took the sex offender's side
what's more they said that if a male sex
pest shows his erection to you in the
locker room
it is your responsibility as a woman
to accept him as a woman
a woman with an erection to be specific
this is the actual position
of the corporate press
and the entire american left wing
if a sex offender is harassing or
assaulting you
you have to put up with it if he says
he's trans
take it one step further
a male sex offender
has the right to harass you
and expose himself to you if he says
he's trans
being transgender grants him the right
to commit sex offenses that is the
official position of the media and the
left and all these people
for the left especially those in the
media
what we what we know and what we learn
from this is that their fidelity to
their religion and to the lgbt agenda
comes before everything else
before the facts before truth
before the privacy and safety of women
and girls before basic human decency
before morality before everything
now we know that
and we're accustomed to it by now we're
kind of numb to it
but that shouldn't prevent us from
realizing
and appreciating just how outrageous and
repugnant all of this really is
if you enjoyed this video be sure to
give it a thumbs up and share with all
your friends